immer wieder wurde ich in letzter zeit
gefragt ob der warp antrieb
funktionieren könnte oder nur etwas für
sein fitschen ist das spannende daran
ist ja wirklich dafür wissenschafter
gibt die konzepte für diesen antrieb
entworfen haben aber könnte man ihn
aufbauen
es gibt immer mehr ich sag mal puzzle
steinchen die es wahrscheinlich machen
ein antrieb der reisen schneller als das
licht ermöglicht jetzt in klicks und 20
zum herbst bekommen
es ist wirklich zu wecken die
relativitätstheorie hat uns unsere
grenzen aufgezeigt und die heißen
zusammengefasst hier kommt hier nicht
weg das universum ist eigentlich für
jeden bewohner ein gefängnis ist
unmöglich größere distanzen zu
überbrücken denn umso schneller wir
reisen desto schwerer werden wir reisen
in die zukunft und es wird immer mehr
energie benötigt um auch nur ein
bisschen zu beschleunigen und mit
heutigen antrieben würde sie jahre
dauern wobei die treibstoffmenge
unfasslich wie schwer es gibt also
zahlreiche grenzen die uns hier
aufgezeigt werden und wir sehen sie
schon daran dass entfernungen im weltall
in sicht jahren angegeben werden ein
lichtjahr ist die entfernung die das
licht in einem jahr zurücklegt und
schneller als licht können wir uns nicht
im raum bewegen und selbst die
lichtgeschwindigkeit wäre eben nur mit
einem nicht zu bewältigenden aufwand zu
erreichen oder knackte
lichtgeschwindigkeit doch science
fiction autoren haben eine lösung für
dieses problem gefunden den warp antrieb
schon 1948 fenster in seinem roman des
leitzinses darling davon und wir kennen
alle aus star trek von gene roddenberry
und nicht selten liegen fan fiction
autoren der nicht so falsch jules verne
zum beispiel hat die mondlandung
vorausgesehen
ein u boot nautilus war atom betrieben
dafür schon verrückt und liegen jetzt
vielleicht science fiction autor mit dem
warp antrieb richtig die idee dahinter
stammt aus verfügt durch die
rotverschiebung von licht im universum
wissen wir dass sich das universum also
der raum ausgehend die unabänderliche
lichtgeschwindigkeit verändert sich also
doch nicht aus entfernten galaxien kommt
bei uns rot verschoben also mit einer
niedrigeren
länger an es wurde quasi gebremst oder
gebiet allerdings ist das de facto nicht
der fall der raum in dem man sich bewegt
er hat sich währenddessen ausgedient
denn raum ist von diesem gesetz nicht
abhängig raum kann sich vollkommen
unabhängig bewegen aus denen
zusammengedrückt werden und das auch
schneller als wörtlich die idee ist
deshalb super windel und genial dann
verändern dir doch einfach den raum die
raumzeit und verkürzen die strecke
zwischen start und ziel wir wollten
ihnen wir drücken ihm zusammen nichts
anderes macht der warp antrieb vor dem
raumschiff drückt das raumschiff den
raum zusammenhang gerät dadurch dichter
anziehen und hinter sich wird er wieder
gesehen aber wie müsste ein solcher
antrieb gebaut sein und da kommen wir
ganz schnell an ein paar kleine
hindernisse zum ersten mal hat miguel
kobe er das durchgerechnet allerdings
war für seinen antritt so viel materie
mit negativer muscle nötig dass es nicht
zu dass wirklich praktikabel war zehn
milliarden mal mehr solcher materie war
nötig als wir ganz normaler materie im
universum
tja blöd werden wir wohl nicht
zusammenkriegen aber inzwischen wurde an
al khobar gleichungen noch einiges
verbessert und der bedarf konnte einen
auch reduziert werden der us-forscher
carole white konnte den bedarf auf
einige hundert kilogramm denken oh wow
das klingt ja jetzt gar nicht mehr so
ganz unrealistisch aber moment wofür sie
eigentlich nötig die idee ist dabei dass
materie und negativer materie
gegenseitig mit dem raum interagieren
und ihm eben vor dem ausschuss
zusammendrücken und dahinter wieder
expandieren normale materie würde dabei
kavitation erzeugen und die negative
materie anti gravitation und wir wissen
ja dass gravitation die raumzeit kriegt
eigentlich genial einfach aber woher
negative materien in materie die andere
materie abstößt ein verrückter gedanke
niemand hat sie bisher gesehen moment
niemand da war doch was
die obduktion wir haben darüber
berichtet da wurde doch gerade vor
kurzem besichtigt forscher haben
negative materie erzeugt sich verdient
sich wie ein magnet der einen anderen
magneten abstellt in einem
bose-einstein-kondensat konnte genau das
beobachtet werden
wir sind also dem wort antrieb ein
ganzes stück näher gekommen doch
trotzdem
also selbst wenn wir in dieser richtung
weiterkommen würden bleiben erhebliche
probleme leider das schiff wäre in einer
toplage nicht steuerbar das innere der
blase könnte sich bei reisen schneller
als das licht durch die hawking
strahlung so stark aufheizen dass alles
darin verbrennt beim abbremsen könnte
eine solche schockwelle entstehen dass
alles im weg zerstören würde inklusive
des reiseziels
denn das ist eine konsequenz dieses
antriebs er krümmt den raum sowie ein
schwarzes loch und hat mit seiner
immensen gravitation erheblichen
einfluss auf seine umgebung aber es ist
unglaublich spannend wie sich die
möglichkeiten des wolfs antrieb wie ein
puzzle zusammensetzen theoretisch aber
eben auch praktisch wie zum beispiel
durch die entdeckung der negativen
materie wir halten euch hier natürlich
auf dem laufenden wenn er alles neue zum
wolf antrieb erfahren wollt dann wird
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
mich den auf die glocke dann verpasst
ihr auf jeden fall kein video hier geht
es zu den besten videos häufig zum
science fiction einfach nur mein flogen
also drauf klicken und staunt und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran